I use my phone incessantly my phone is
basically my boredom box so anytime I've
get really bored that's the first thing
I go to I'm so attached to my phone it's
almost embarrassing like I never put it
down ever Oh God cuz I had to guess I
would say maybe around 45 minutes a day
humid Lee maybe condense it all together
a hour and a half I think I'm on my
phone like an hour well maybe like 13
hours like a day I feel like I don't
check my phone that much I've always
kind of tried to pride myself on being
one of those people so I would guess I
checked my phone 30 times a day there's
a like big period of time where I don't
look at it
I've been sitting here for ages I have a
feeling I might not like what I find out
but I know I probably am NOT going to
change I am so scared that I am the
problem I am the person that I hate you
know it's weird
my phone is such a big part of my life
and I have no idea how much I use it so
now I'm home and this is definitely when
I check my phone a lot more it's
actually kind of embarrassing how much
I've been using my phone okay so
confession time I'm at a dinner with
friends and the first thing I did was go
on my phone to check my email so I'm
home from work now and I'm gonna guess
my phone usage is gonna double or triple
so I'm checking
my Instagram in the shower I'm trying to
get off my phone so I can go to bed I
feel like I check it more compulsively
than I imagined but maybe for not quite
as long I don't know we'll see what
happens tomorrow I'm really nervous to
find out how much I actually use my
phone like I didn't realize how many
things I use my phone for that I didn't
really put in my estimate terrified of
what this will say about me all right
here we go Oh movies I want oh no whoa
151 times holy I got business to attend
so I got a reply to everybody
whoa that is not anywhere near as bad as
I thought it would be three hours and
like totally fine with ya the stews
right this is right this is a
mind-blowing knowing myself oh my god oh
I was completely wrong I'm like oh oh my
god whoo okay 138 hiccups to me ah
that's a lot of checking my phone that's
a lot of just constantly like huh huh
huh I was very wrong
I really disgusted myself this is
horrible
um I don't think though I think it's
gonna change what apps I spend time with
on my phone I make fun of my friends so
much for being on their phone while I'm
talking to them now I know clearly I
have also one of those people for all of
my friends who make fun of me for being
on my phone all the time I'm actually
fairly average so my phone's gonna be a
big part of my life still but I'm gonna
try to use it in a more healthy way it
makes me think that maybe I spend way
too much time stuck down like this and
it wouldn't kill me to keep my head here
more often during the day and my life